so another part of red pill i have a
question um do you guys think body count
matters
yes yes 100 is this for both genders
yeah uh for women let's say for women
and then the firm i do women than men so
okay oh not for men no no matters for
your god women yes
men
not so much okay
no neither
okay
i don't think it
i think it only matters
how it's put out there
because somebody a woman can have a high
body count nobody knows about it she
carries herself or even men would know
about it and she carries herself
different member treats are different
but you can have somebody without a high
body cat not even as high as that
woman's body care and it's all out there
for everyone to see it's all over the
internet
then it matters because you must know
women that got high high body cats you
still respect them because of the way
they carry themselves and normally it's
the older woman not the younger woman
because there's lots of older women out
there with high body cats and people
still respect them they're the aunties
they're the grandmas
but then you get the young women now and
they've got a high body can
and it's like a badge of honor
wouldn't you say it makes you less
valuable to men though the more men you
sleep with
yeah yeah the women don't know that
because they're always trying to get
that better man
what women don't know that women
definitely know that well no no it's
it's like a coke if they did why would
we sleep in the summer because if
anybody can i'll just why would they
bother i'll just lie
yeah i'll just um just a quick stat only
30 percent of
wait um
when a woman gets married and she's a
virgin she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if she slept with more than
five people it drops to thirty percent
ah wow
that means that i'm at two percent
what did you do
it's gonna be i've gotta be at two
percent or something like that
yeah and it does it's not like the end
it's not saying like every single girl
that slept around like that's her fate
but
it's i think to say that like sleeping
around has a good
is good for women is kind of a lie that
feminism teaches go ahead i think it's
bad for women
i think it's bad for both but more so
for women because
with men there's a pride attached to it
with women there's a stigma attached to
it
so i think nowadays the women are trying
to turn that stigma into pride and it's
not working
that's where the modern women get lost
because that stigma of having a high
body count is no longer there they're
wearing it with pride i think it also
like from a male point of view it also
depends on the people she slept with to
a point as well because if for example
say you live in one of those areas and a
lot of people know each other
okay one of men's biggest i don't want
to say nightmares but hang ups is
bumping into another guy
like oh i know your girl like i know
her
sorry i think yeah you go actually the
point so
body con
for men
so when you're approaching a girl
because it actually touching your
confidence so since you know that your
women actually slept with 10 20 other
men
you like losing confidence
and your like worry your first word is
like you know
get to know
yeah you don't exactly slept with
so it's about you not about us well but
if you give something away for free it's
not valuable so if you if you
if you're giving it to a lot of people
it's not valuable so why that doesn't
like go
off away right because because men and
women are different women are born with
value where men have men have to create
their values so for you to want to sleep
with a guy he's got to be tall he's got
to be good looking he's got to have a
job like he has to do things one out of
three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year and
women are sleeping with five to 20
percent of guys so the reason like women
hate men is because we're all sleeping
with the same ones i'm not agreeing
about this honestly um because
the fact you as he said the fact you
slept with multiple men or whatever how
many they are doesn't really it depends
like was you actually in a relationship
with him
oh it was just occasional
thing you know
and i also accept occasional stuff like
because
you know like if you match
someone and you you know you just want
to enjoy your day there's nothing wrong
with that and that's honestly no one
allows her men to tell me are less
vulnerable than someone else that had
sex just once
well it's not it's like it's not cause
my body gonna be the same body
and myself going to be the same person
after 10 20 men it wouldn't change it's
not it's not anything about who you are
as a person but it's what men value so
you can't so so you can't go up to guys
and say don't value this because it's
what they want so that's like me selling
a car and going up to the people that
want to buy a car and say like this car
and they say no i don't want to buy that
car because it's got too many miles and
you're saying well you should like cars
with high miles
yeah
with the women honestly we're talking
about completely different so women
can't get no title like that because
when she's saying that nobody's gonna
know you have about thirty men you're
gonna be as loose as hell the men know
and like the thing is you know and at
the end of the day every woman sleeps
with loads of men she's a she's a [ __ ]
every man man sleeps with loads of women
he's a stud yeah so that goes to show
from the beginning and that's i'm sorry
you
we didn't make that rule as well no but
that but that's the way it is
and at the end of the day right men
can have loads of sex and it's always
going to be like women
yeah so
that's the only way i can put it you're
going to you're going to know
you can't say oh it's my
body because you're going to be cause
you're going to be no amount of lime and
salt can help you yeah because you get
trauma from everyone
like you can't you can't say like a very
okay that that girl that came in earlier
you could tell she hadn't slept with a
lot of people because she was just so
nice and like like you can like feel it
on a girl right because they're not
they're not like traumatized because if
you sleep with 20 30 40 guys the odds
that one is gonna hurt you is like
higher and higher and higher like how do
you go through that many guys and none
hurt you come on
just because you're having sex with him
they are to you for a lot of other
reasons and doesn't matter this sex like
it's not about sex
he actually asks you when he does
something wrong i don't think he does
something wrong in bad it can do
something wrong you know in any other
occasion
actually probably they're gonna be
good in bed and then probably doing
but that's but that's like a masculine
trait is not being able to bond with men
through sex because women tend to bond
with men through sex unless they've
slept with a lot of people then they
don't why we don't just think about that
our women can enjoy sex out as a man
like
yeah
like you can enjoy catching feelings no
matter what
that's what you like to think
that's what you like to think no you
know i just know quick quick just around
guys in the room i'm just asking have
you ever slept with a girl that said it
was casual and then she caught feelings
yes yes um ish
have you ever slept with a girl that
casually and then she caught feelings
yeah
dude i don't know your name but yes yes
yeah give me yes or no yeah yeah okay so
four random guys are in this room all
saying this yeah what about the opposite
why you didn't ask me what do you mean
if i stop any kind of you know
relationship with them because we
weren't because we weren't talking about
you we were talking about the men yeah i
mean as a woman no me as a alessandra
like if that can happen for a man it's
tough to see someone
because it was catching feeling that can
happen also with a man the only thing is
um that men usually they just don't say
when they catch him feeling because they
feel
like you know we
it's the stereotype of men
so it's not allowed to say yeah i'm
falling in love just having sex with
with you so he wouldn't say that he
wouldn't say that no but like pearl said
we don't really there's always going to
be exceptions to the rule but the
reality is it doesn't work both ways and
listen if a man catches feelings for a
woman he's with that woman forever yes
he's going to stick with her and that's
the difference if a woman if a woman
catches his feelings she's going to
chase that man even though it's a
one-night stand but for monkey
experience then that's his woman
that is his woman simple as that because
men hold men hold access or women are in
control of sex men are in control of
relationships